courage is an external thing right so I  have met people who literally have  courage what we would call courage they  have put their lives on the line they've  thrown themselves into harm's way in  order to save the life of someone else  they have done something that we would  consider mad that violates all tenets of  survived you knows that we're supposed  to do things to make to survive so that  someone else will survive current real  courage and I've talked to them and I  think always say why did you do it  you've got a wife you've got kids why  would you do that they all give me the  same answer  every time because they would have done  it for me because someone else would  have done the same for me it is the  absolute confidence that the person to  the left and the person to the right  will do the same for me that gives them  the courage to do amazing things  [Music]